hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of all
verses I hate westerns well except for
Tombstone that was pretty good
oh and I'm forgiven that's not bad also
the good the bad and the ugly that was
pretty awesome
oh do the searchers now that's a classic
but luckily this film has nothing to do
fucking maverick man that was a funny
movie okay okay there's a lot of good
westerns out there but nevertheless this
review has nothing to do with Western
fucking yep it's true great the film
that launched a dozen Oscars twice this
timeless tale of a girl seeking the help
of a one-eyed cowboy one audiences over
in the late 1960s but then all of the
sudden the Coen brothers came along and
made what many consider to be a damn
good remake and of course we all loved
it
why because it's the dude playing a
cowboy the fucking awesome is that the
dude abides but which film holds up the
best over time which one is stronger
more poignant and for like a better word
prettier well in this rendition of old
versus new we're gonna look at True Grit
or as I like to call it how many Big
Lebowski jokes can I make you one review
first let's look at our main character
at the film Maddy best supporting
actress my ass she's a big character we
all know it you're going first man come
on
chop
something you're gonna hear me say a lot
in this review is they're both really
good and both these performances are no
exception but they are different
the original was played by Kim Darby she
offers a determination and a great need
to overcome her fears to get justice for
the death of her father when we locate
Chaney we can jump him in the same way
penny mom had with sticks and documents
sensible in the remake it's a least I
felt
she's also determined as hell but to an
extreme level I mean really extreme when
Janie is taken he's coming back to Fort
Smith to hang I'm to get top training if
you were not game I will find somebody
who is I'm afraid nothing is going to be
done about Chaney except I do it Jesus
to the point where she doesn't even seem
human
she's like an unstoppable vengeance
machine not go back not without Chaney
dead or alive so this creates an
interesting split you have one
performance that's determined but also
realistic and even slightly frightened
by the danger she's going to get into
name is Tom Chaney
he's a whisky drinker like he'd been to
killing in the end I feel just answer
the marshals questions he'll help you
and then you had the old crazily
obsessed little girl version of a
terminator I killed him I would not be
now when this fix my revolver misfired
which one is better well the original
version seems more realistic you know
that women especially girls back then
were not often trained to go on man
hunts so her reactions to a lot of these
grisly situations seems more believable
Schumer comes her fear but she shows
that there is fear to overcome the remix
shows her own says bitter and cold and
her lust for vengeance blinds her to
anything else
she doesn't care what's in the way she
just wants to find the bastard who
killed her daddy and see him Hank
nothing else can scare her and nothing
else seems of any importance and to be
honest that's what makes her more
interesting while the other version
seems more realistic this version has
much more dry no time for distractions
and is extremely fixated on nothing else
but getting her killer it's kind of
fascinating to see a child this
intelligent and hungry for blood I mean
have you ever counted how often she
smiles in this movie it's close to never
because she is so different from our set
what a girl in that time period would be
like that's all the more reason to find
her more engaging to follow and that
makes us all the more interested in
what's going to happen in the end what
both performances are very good it's the
remake that gives us the character that
were simply more interested in following
what goes to the new I hope you go to
jail
and now we go from cowgirl the cowboy
who's better the Duke or the dude
another tough choice is choosing who's
the best rendition of rooster cogburn
and to be fair you can't really judge
the performances unless you judge the
actors pass John Wayne for example he's
an iconic legend but he was also best at
playing John Wayne you never saw his
films to see him slip into different
characters or roles he saw him to play
John Wayne he did it will he did it very
well nobody could play John Wayne like
John Wayne first night out you'd be
calling mama mama cryin here's $25 Oh
but to be honest it love very few
surprises in what you were gonna get
like could you see John Wayne playing
The Joker anytime soon why so serious
Jeff Bridges on the other hand has
played many different kinds of roles but
in my humble opinion I very rarely see
the character as much as I do Jeff
Bridges playing the character it's kind
of like Kevin Spacey's acting I'm always
aware he's playing a part it doesn't
mean he's bad or anything it's just I'm
always aware he's playing the role with
the exception of a few parts I'm the
dude and obviously that goes without
saying
luckily though this is one of those
roles he totally gets lost in bridges is
perfect as the drunk but still
relatively badass gun sight he said in
pathetic in many ways but also likable
and threatening when he needs to be he
was a perfect choice would you revolver
in hand and then loaded and cocked off
like loading cognate don't you which one
is truly the better character well
taking out the fact that we know we're
gonna be watching John Wayne plain John
Wayne it's still a good performance he's
tough he's cunning and he does whatever
the hell he wants which means when he
really does care for somebody like
Maddie it's all the more meeting they
must all been married men had loved
their families because they scattered
and run for a home riches is much more
of a doubt but he gets drunk he really
gets drunk and when he gets angry he
really gets angry nothing is really
glorified about him apart from maybe is
gun slinging it's just sort of a lost
soul who tries to do what's right that
is what it's convenient don't believe
birthday
sermons restores about money better
shipping but thanks for the cigarette
but again that's what makes him so
interesting his character is so
confident in his abilities yet so
hate-filled when it comes to his life he
constantly abuses himself and cares
little about his actions again that's
what makes his conviction to Maddie's
case more engaging but at the same time
he flip-flops like anyone who's insecure
drinks as much as he does take the girl
about about to walk my hand John Wayne
is the hero sure he's fought but we all
know he'll do the right thing in the end
this guy is just all over the place
which makes it much more unpredictable
we don't always know if he's reliable
or even sober when John Wayne gets drunk
it's cute when this guy gets drunk it's
scary the only truly gives us the more
uncontrollable hero and because of that
it's more fun to see what he's going to
do and how he's gonna do sorry dude but
in this contest bridges plays the more
entertaining goal point again goes to
the new I ought to paddle your rump
look good is our own adventure if you
don't have a bunch of little doggies
good god did I really write that oh god
I was trans this is fest boring cast
now you think because this is a Coen
Brothers movie there'd be a lot more
interesting side characters in this film
their movies practically star the Sai
characters but the original has some
good ones as well for example we do see
the relationship debrief between Maddy
and her father yet he seems like a nice
enough guy to go and be avenged in the
remake you don't even see her father he
just shows up deal way characters like
the banker are great in both movies as
they both give deservingly over-the-top
performances ha would not pay three
hundred and twenty-five dollars for
Wynyard Pegasus I wouldn't pay that for
winged Pegasus but of course the big
focus is on the bull the bow shine I
don't know the other cowboy the original
is played by Glenn Campbell while the
wemake is played by Matt Damon
now Campbell looks like he belongs in a
cowboy movie looks naive but
nevertheless has some idea about how to
take care of himself that big dumb grin
how cannot like this guy and you dear
lady I found a sweet distraction as I
supposed most men do were your excuses
well he does have his tough moments his
chipper attitude shows he's clearly in
over his head in the remake on the other
hand Damon plays it a little different
he's in over his head too but not in the
same way he's buried by the book and I
get the feeling that he wants to be
taken seriously he wants to be the
heroic leader but he is nevertheless out
of place why did you not catch him in
Pine Bluff Arkansas I'm on Rowe
Louisiana he is a crafty one I saw him
slow-witted myself that was his act it
was a good one
both are very effective and served the
story great however many argue that Matt
Damon didn't belong in this movie that
he didn't look like the traditional
cowboy character but oddly enough I
think that works to the film's advantage
in many ways he shouldn't be there and
when he takes off it actually seems very
fitting adding character and I think
that because someone like Matt Damon is
playing him that comes across much
stronger again kind of a tough call but
I think I'm gonna go with the Rieman why
because it has the bear guy in it I mean
who was that where did he come from
what's his story we'll never know if I
god it's killing us trying to find out
now I have taken his teeth I will
entertain
for the race giving me far out that guy
was awesome point goes to the new I love
the bear guy I'm of a mind to give you
five or six good licks with my belt
and now it's time for the bad guy the
varmints that started this whole just
Segway with a big lebowski joke human
paraquat thank you this is best villains
now something that I love in both of
these movies is that the killer that
Maddie is going after is not a
mastermind it's not a diabolical genius
he's not charismatic he's not even very
smart he's just some idiot drunk and you
know what that's actually kind of
refreshing let's face it a lot of
killings in the Old West happen because
well there were a lot of idiot drums and
they had guns and if anything he's
actually following the more charismatic
smarter villain that makes the story
seem much more real and unlike
traditional westerns one is played by
Jeff quarry I know you little Mattie the
bookkeeper and the other is played by
Josh Brolin I don't think you're enjoy
what do you think now now I'm shot by
Tom again both are good but I think
Reese is a little bit more pathetic I
feel like the more lo the character is
the more in vain the murder is which
again makes for a different but much
stronger story but if we're gonna look
at him we might as well look at the
leader - this is Ned pepper played in
the remake by Barry Pepper known COAS it
does and in the original by Robert
Duvall I never busted a cap on a woman
or nobody much under 16 but it's enough
that you know I'll do what I have to do
you know Barry Pepper does a really good
job as the leader and seems totally
legit well he's going up against Robert
fucking Duvall I'm sorry that's a really
hard act to follow this guy much like
the bear guy you really want to know
more about something about the way he
speaks and holds himself just a man's
presence I'm happy done what he done but
he should have kept his head and looked
out for herself
those were your good friend rooster like
this was the main villain from a
different movie but somehow got roped
into this one like this guy really
wanted no part with these people
like he had much bigger stories he was
involved with but then somehow got mixed
up in this bullshit that one of his
henchmen started again that sort of adds
to the shit happens effect of face
movies it's great it's absolutely great
so let's give credit where credit's due
the original really did have the better
middles sorry guys
you did good - just not asking play goes
to the old Mustang over my position
how I may improve
and now the defining point that always
settles it
the story
fascinates me about this film and it's
remake is how different they are and yet
how almost identical they are sure
there's little changes like the bear guy
in the hanging person but when you're
walking through it's almost seen for
seeing the same the only major
difference is the beginning and the
ending in the original opening we see
Maddie interact with her father but in
the remake he's already dead and the
ending well we'll get to that in a
minute the other core difference really
is in style and tone the original is a
basic revenge story where good wins in
the end then justice has its way in a
remake it's much more dark and empty
maddie is obsessed on the beginning with
getting her man that's the focus on this
version the obsession in the original
she gets her revenge and everything
seems great he's happy her dad's avenged
John Wayne gets a little smile and he
rides off to more adventure just like
most John Wayne movies in the remake
yeah it's not so simple Maddie loses her
arm from the snake bite which by the way
I feel really sorry for the snake in the
original look at this thing somebody
called fucking PETA
anyway Maddie loses her arm rooster
leaves after dropping her off to safety
keeping in character and she doesn't
ever see him again we cut two years
later when she grows a bitter and cold
finding that her revenge is actually
filled very little she only finds out
later where and when rooster died and
even then it's not so heroic she visits
his grave walks away and that's it there
is no grand ending no riding on the
horse no cowboy music playing it sucks
all the romance out of it and shows the
emptiness that such an obsession will
ultimately get you it's not a happy
ending I guess but it's not a sad ending
either yeah I guess it's just very very
hollow but that seems more fitting for
this story and let's be honest a child
that grows up with that kind of thirst
for violence probably won't lead a
normal happy life she probably would be
a lonely stick in the mud with little to
smiland
and again it's a very refreshing take
from the kill the bad guy and everything
is fine motif than most westerns
following so because of
even though the stories are very similar
we got very different versions and the
better one as you probably imagine is
the one with more complexity and depth
the newer version I have to admit I feel
bad that I've given most of the points
to the new version even though the old
one is very good too they're both great
movies for what they are and deserve to
be watched and recognized it's just that
when you put them back-to-back the new
one really does have more to offer it's
darker grittier
and leaves much more of an image so it
you can guess the best story also comes
from the best version the new true print
the superior film
so thank you all for watching I hope you
had a good time and well if there's
anything I know how to do its how to end
a Western I'll end a Schnauzer Craig I
remember it so you don't have
don't vine leaning on the everlasting
arms
blessing
now I have taken his teeth